[Music]
all right we're taking it back to
Australia
oh down all right an Australian man has
been caught red-handed after spending
the night with a sex worker and lying to
his partner oh classic very classic
crime here is it legal there I I heard
it was really in Australia yeah it's
legal to what whole country just a bunch
of convicts speak on it used to be jail
right I mean I just heard that that's
where Britain sent all their convicts a
bunch of Outlaws so then you would
imagine they' be
unruly that's a good word to use but
that's all I heard a little mischievous
that's just what I've heard where all
the Vietnamese people come from
though Vietnam true that's a good answer
okay so this is how this is how it uh
this is how went who you vote for who
the [__] what the [__] show am I on yeah
here's how it went down down John Cary
in a text to
his significant other um he sent on New
Year's Eve actually read it in an
Australian accent though so it's
authentic I'm not that good we need Ryan
here let try try oh I need a couple of
words so I can build off of it again
Ryan's going to down
un down Australia in a text to his other
half sent K New Year
after telling his Ms he was going to say
his financial guy oh now it's going a
little brick hey we need more
fluctuation the tone is where it goes
yeah but where have Vietnamese people
come from it's that you know what it is
py
Blinder do py Blinder you're watching a
lot of py blinders I like it I like it
do you guys think I should start
watching it [__] blinders that's
really it is kind of my culture now
should I start watching it PE blinders
yeah cuz my relatives do you like really
cool swaggy [__] isn't that I don't it's
[__] [__] cool man [__] maybe I need
to watch it it's Fu I don't watch any of
these new shows dude kilan Murphy is
like chef's kiss so good like him all
right so uh Asian one thank you that's
I'll take that as a compliment all right
so he was telling his M he was going to
see his financial guy so this is how it
gets funny all right uh and he claims
that he'd suddenly been kidnapped or
taken by Middle Eastern men and was
being held hostage over a $7,000 dirt F
this guy's racist too he's like oh my
god I've been kidnapped oh I don't know
this girl rescued me who do I blame and
I had to repay her so we [__] no no no
the guys Middle Eastern men kidnapped
him and they were holding him ransom for
$7,000 or $7,000 a terrorist with
Australian
[Music]
accent that was really good that's
pretty good so that's what he said okay
muffled but it was
good so he he would send her a message
and he would say uh to his partner uh
it's and then leas her name thank you
for sending Paul to me now payback is a
[__] bye-bye but I'm going to be fair
okay we will keep him with us until
tomorrow when he gives us his bike we
call it square no one's touching him my
word I'll give you okay so that's his
text sir seems like a little much just
sounds like [__] Action Moving lies
like a Vista yeah oh no babe they're
making me [__] hookers now oh no I got
to do what they say I don't want to but
his plan kind of doesn't work cuz he
called the cops cuz his girlfriend ends
up contacting the police for help of
course like yeah it would make like a
total lady bro ruining the party tell
the police they'll kill me freaking
ladies dude the police launched an
immediate response to the incident and
conduct a high-risk vehicle stop and
it's around 10:30 a.m. the next day that
his um his the day after his text that
police discovered him in his own van the
36-year-old originally told police he'd
been kidnapped but this story began to
look unlikely when officials obtain CCTV
footage of him with a sex worker from
his night of fun on New Year's Eve a few
days later and said that the police
spent a staggering 200 hours
investigating the hoax and now he has
been slapped with a huge fine because of
it do we know that the sex holder wasn't
holding him at gunpoint and making him
[__] over
motorc you need to be a part of his
legal team immediately I think I would
I'd do
it such wait was he caught in the car
with her on CCTV oh yeah men are scum
but it's also like men are trash trash
Australian so they're all unruly anyway
they're also from Australia I think
women should run the world I think I
think Taylor Swift should be president
after stories like this men are idiots
who needs men not me do you guys want to
take a quick Victory lap around the
around the desks cuz I
do men are trash men are [__] garbage
he really is the woo man though you know
the woo man I love mother I love Taylor
Swift I want her to be president I want
her to run the world thank you dude take
another lap
bro
[Applause]
[Laughter]
going yeah why lies so big yeah it's
just why go from like uh cheer going to
cheat man well I know but just like
that's a good point what would your lie
yeah like oh I'm I'm going to be at
Nick's house we're playing poker too
late and she calls Nick yeah but then
Nick's going to cover for me way more
likely than the police getting held up
at gunpoint over a motorcycle maybe he's
got no friends Nick wouldn't cover for
you that's true but you make up
something hey I'm going I'm going out of
town for the weekend hey I'm going to go
to the mountain it was New Year's Eve
which is a bad day to cheat yeah like
New Year's Eve is a bad day to cheat you
go you go on a holiday when you should
be spending that time with your girl
yeah New Year Eve is a bad day to cheat
you got to choose like a a Wednesday or
some [__] no 100% you're that's the mind
of a cheater thanks Anthony CU it's a
thanks for teaching me thanks for
teaching me how to cheat on a Tuesday
hump day there's probably New Year
specials though you know said years of
experience yeah it sounds like he has
knowledge to pass on Seas vet no no no
I've just been reading a lot of unruly
articles grizzled vet even there is I
just see a pattern and I'm just trying
to figure out what the opposite of it is
yeah it's not very bright cuz we don't
do news articles here about people that
are just successful and got away with it
otherwise we'd be outing them dude
Anthony staying in a log cabin right he
you hear a helicopter land a [__]
General knocks on the door and he's like
Anthony you cheating son of a [__] we
need you back in the [__] game we got
an emergency there's nobody on the earth
who has more experience cheating on
women than you why are you getting R I'm
just he was huffing and puffing getting
off the [__] you know low oxygen when
you're up in the air high stakes dude
he's got to get him back it's an
emergency though prors aren't stopping
yeah it's loud he's like I'm retired I
told you I'm not [__] anymore wood
for some reason that's when they got
Iron Man back for the aveng [__]
retired I need you back in the [__]
Muses are [__] Rippling I told you to
never come back here how did you find
me he's like we can smell your colog
from [__]
Arizona can sex have son of a [__] Cool
Water cologne you
[__] I can't even roll with this cuz
it's real it's so real he'll call us
he'll call no then Anthony takes a
sledgehammer or to of the concrete Crown
right
he starts digging up his old safe where
it has his old outfit Co leather jacket
yeah probably a motorcycle down there
burner cell phone [__] fingerless
gloves the black book with a thousand
[__] numbers in it thousands of
dollars of cash dude they're all got
pictures every chick yeah crates of
condoms yeah yeah his Magnum sponsorship
t-shirt the Kamas Sutra book he takes it
he throws it behind his back he knows he
memorizes it at home STD
test can we bring back JK films for this
one that would have been great yeah
that's good that would be great you're
just talking about [__] like it's to R's
room and then never
executing are you not there in the scene
are you not F can you not there yeah I
felt chill I smell the colog I was in a
winter cabin yeah nany has every
currency in a briefcase five passports
wow in in different continents I'm
either Steve Green or beran or [__]
in every continent some woman comes up
to you and smacks you across the face
you son of a [__] where have you been
yeah you didn't answer my
text I can't play along with that me I
have four kids the next scene starts
with him in the club and a [__] smacks
him in the face they all have four kids
and they're all [__] from one the one
time Anthony left yeah one nut four kids
they're in the back like [__] popping
and locking wiggling around those aren't
mine those arine I don't know what the
[__] you're talking about make it bad
business deals in the
background so what was the article what
happened that that's what we need to fil
Anthony the sex H the sex I hate that
it's funny but I can't play it along
it's all right dude I'm just jealous of
sex haers and his Kryptonite his cryp he
needs needs electrolytes all the time
otherwise he gets too dehydrated from
all the [__] got to save some women
for us can we talk about Nick's movie
now no
n dude my movie is not going to be
anywhere as good as yours we're not
going to even make it it doesn't start
with the [__] General descending from
a it doesn't he's said hop off he's got
to be the general with the eye patch
yeah yeah actually RI horn remember that
RI horn I don't if I don't know ripn
[__] sweet remember men and black
yeah the guy he's the main guy and he
has a voice like this he talk like that
D everything yeah he's good or JK
Simmons dude Simmons a good D JK
Simmons oh that's a good one he would do
it yeah dude but not not the J Jo and
Jameson one the Whiplash one Whiplash
but he also does State Farm commercials
too so he'd probably do our movie yeah
he's looking for work he just wants
money dude I saw him at a flower store
in La once like on Valentine's Day last
minute too cuz we were both in there
last minute he gave me a look like last
minute I'm like last minute that's kind
of cool sick and then he reaches for
like the [__] that you know those
little bouquet they have it's like it's
like a $235 bouquet he's like no [__]
problem whatever I'm trying to get one
flower it's like 50 $5 that's the State
Farm money dude yeah
dude